un vin aux chroniques en duo ou trio est
à moitié ok to fail au congrès
[Musique]
oh
reading
[Musique]
on
non
le grand frère était programmé pour
devenir le président des états unis par
son père l'a forcément l'ambition passe
sur le second c'est john kennedy qui est
beaucoup plus faibles physiquement qui
n'a pas forcément envie de devenir
président mais qui sait que désormais
c'est à lui de répondre à l'injonction
paternel qui en fait qu'on peut résumer
par tu seras président mon fils
[Musique]
et un chiffre d'affaires de 19 ans
et ce soir on est au pied d'un fonds de
commerce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
le
de tous les frères winch xiii ya thérèse
de graines sans esprit de nadia
freephone rendre justice
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la thèse officielle c'est celle d'un
tueur isolé pour des raisons politiques
l'airbus valdes mais aujourd'hui encore
et peut-être pour toujours
on ignore et on ignorera véritablement
ce qui s'est passé ce jour là
on s'éloigne de plus en plus de ce qui
était le réel kennedy qui est devenu
effectivement un peu comme marilyn par
exemple une figure de la de la culture
pop
[Musique]
c'est une figure importante au sein du
parti démocrate en particulier à chaque
élection est certain qu'il ya un nouveau
kennedy qui apparaît pour un jeune
américain kennedy ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire la jeunesse ça veut dire la
beauté ça veut dire l'énergie
ça veut dire la foi dans l'avenir alors
que ce ne sont que 1000 jours au pouvoir
beaucoup de questions sur ce qu'il
aurait fait par la suite mais à la
limite ça ouvre un champ d horizon un
mystère dans lequel s'engouffrent
beaucoup d'imaginaire américains
aujourd'hui